reject nation what's going on today we
are going to be watching
zack snyder's justice league per grace
randolph's interview with zack snyder
where he did a breakdown
of like a viewing session i don't know
still how this is gonna be cut up when
it's all said and done it's gonna be cut
up into several parts where's my shirt
in our world we're watching this at one
go
so we're just gonna be here i got a
pillow we got four hours ahead of us
of awesomeness i'm excited to be on this
journey thank you to everyone who's been
watching our reactions this entire time
eric nerd chronic thanks for cutting
this up i'm sure it's a nightmare
and uh yeah full length watch along
recycle with the time code we'll be over
at our patreon page along with a whole
bunch of other
shows and stuff that we cover this has
been a long journey yeah it's been years
in the making just excited to sit back
relax
and enjoy it uh i feel like this is just
gonna be a
it's a great experience i'm really
excited thank you guys uh let's do it
i'm feeling
feeling really grateful right now let's
get into it
oh my god i can't believe it's here that
is so weird
[Music]
yeah this is gonna be so [ __ ] cool
oh god
scream is awakening the mother boxes
yeah
well i love how too it's taking like one
of the climactic moments of
the previous direct installment and then
using it to kind of form the whole
introduction
yeah yeah steppenwolf right there
it's not the deleted deleted scene
oh [ __ ]
ah so eerie
this already feels like so much better
structure
these things that we're just sort of
mcguffins and the justice league now
feels
such a great consequence yeah look at
that they're all just waiting what
put that motherbox
oh brave amazon
david fulis is in this okay i'm turning
in his errors
i wasn't sure for sure about that
i bet this looks incredible on an imax
oh yeah no but this comes out on imax
i'm going like i can already tell just
like how much detail is getting crunched
down into the screen we're watching on
gotta get the freaking aquaman
gotta find this aquaman
oh my god i can't believe we're good
it's just like this doesn't feel real
this doesn't feel real well i love how
much time this
is in setting the mood this is taken
because it's slowly starting
yeah i love it
my favorite batman right here people
i don't know what's in christeria and
josh sweden
boom guys just a christario screenplay
there should just be an extra credit
that says oh and [ __ ] joshua
talk i believe there is a stranger
comes to this village from the sea it's
very important that i see this man
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
look i saw you in my email
i have a video clip get out
i'll leave after we've spoken he said
get out
i've read the stories you're good deeds
you think no one sees
you'll join us strong man as strong as
alone
you ever heard that you ever hear a
superman
he died fighting next to me my point
exactly we owe it to him
i don't know anyone anything
except my trainer
[Music]
so nice to see that shot actually look
good with him in the water yeah
this like mystical buildup of aquaman
[Music]
the culture yeah
[Music]
sorry it's like so much more new lots of
[Applause]
[Music]
details
are she leaving smallville it looks like
it
hmm that's too bad come on bruce pony up
good morning miss lane jerry hi you
don't miss a day do you
like it here
oh she starts a ring on
oh
i love how each one of his films just
looks so different in this trilogy
yeah and feels good yeah i love that
it's been like [ __ ] freaking dark
night yeah
freaking dark side
[Music]
this is really hard
oh now that was legit
oh
oh no swallow it like the mask
dude in the matter of like a few seconds
she whooped ass
look at the blood on the wall dude smash
that guy to that wall
boom
it's like indy pulling out the gun
i love that like angelic
tribal amazonian like music that plays
for her
yeah that like vocalization before the
guitar
sets in it's over now okay okay
oh look at her she's actually connecting
to the youth
you okay princess can i be like you
someday
you can be anything you want to be
since you're saying like i literally
just watched wonder woman again
yesterday so to
get like the zack snyder visual language
of it all is
very very interesting the motherbox has
awoken
yet nothing has happened why did it wake
at all
this is the first time it's gone quiet
since the crack appeared
maybe it's going back to sleep evil does
not sleep
it waits
good good timing hippolyta
i have come to enlighten you to the
great darkness
i will bathe in your fears
holy crap
no oh man
oh damn oh
yeah ladies
how buff
hell yeah dude
it's cool that they actually get to make
her look like a badass in this one too
yeah
you really see why she has the saddest
that she does yeah
wow oh
all those lives sacrificed
[Music]
yeah this is what this is [ __ ] good
you just like oh oh my god
[Music]
god look at the colors on that thing oh
oh my god those poor horses
oh
oh my god i'm in love with this
this is so well staged oh damn
they truly feel like warriors
oh poor horsey of them
oh [ __ ] damn
see that's how you create peril
so you create tension and stakes we have
to light the ancient warning fire
men won't know what it means men won't
she will
it's a good thing she left that's the
end of part one of our reaction to zack
cider's justice league
keep a lookout for part two or if part
two is already up
there should be a card above me pin
comment the end screen card top of this
description box
it'll all be updated if it's there
already
or keep a lookout weird scheduling
[Music]